meanwhile lesbian Kellyanne cow Conway
longtime counselor to the president
helped him get reelected in 2016 imagine
at some point help them keep that job
through 2024 Kelly and welcome back as
you see the president's guy I see the
president's out a visiting Honeywell
plan he's going to be out and about a
little bit more but I'm really struck by
that report that came out that New York
Times got ahold of put out by FEMA that
says with seven hundred and seventeen
hundred and fifty people lose their
lives to the the covert 19 that's going
to go up to three thousand by June first
a 70 percent increase are those the
numbers that you that did you heard
circular around the White House to well
the White House yesterday clearly said
Brian that and good morning that the
task force did not generate that
document and no one at the task force to
my knowledge has been asked to review it
and scrub the data and agree with it I
think the most important thing to note
is that the president has said all along
though that we are going to have death
and destruction what we've been trying
to do here is to mourn the dead and
grieve with those who have lost loved
ones and then to try to mitigate the
damage from this invisible enemy that's
why this president's on things only a
president can do joining forces with
companies like Honeywell to develop high
quality n95 masks respirators deploying
these ventilators to every state
everybody needed the ventilator got a
ventilator working with Democratic
governors who are accrediting him and
lauding our efforts to collaborate with
them not compete with them dealing with
the other g7 late leaders because this
is a global pandemic repatriating 62,000
Americans who were abroad when the
pandemic started to really metastasize
all these things that only a president
can do signing into law three
consecutive packages over three trillion
dollars in direct relief and and the
president is going to continue to do
that we know that additional deaths
sadly will continue what we're trying to
do is show that this health care
president is the one that is governing
and directing his FDA to approve
pharmaceuticals and devices in record
time sometime
it would take four to six years if it's
done in four to six weeks same thing at
HHS and CMS these hospital rules and
regulations have been relaxed this
president of 100 billion now plus for
the hospitals for reimbursement that's a
significant amount of money because
about a third of that is going to cover
covert expenses for the uninsured this
healthcare president started out with
transparency surprise medical billing
kidney health decreasing your Medicare
premiums but now the National Guard's
and they're sanitizing nursing homes
now the VA said last week it's it's
tested all of its vetted all the people
in its veterans nursing homes we're
going to continue to bring testing
online and and that's what we're focused
on that the healthcare president
continued to deliver for America at this
time of the pandemic crisis and other
health care needs Kelly and tell us why
he decided to go to Honeywell he's
flying over to Arizona today why well
Honeywell has been one of many private
sector partners who really stepped in
and stepped up on behalf of this country
Aynsley in this case Honeywell committed
to and in fact delivered on its
commitment to produce high quality and
95 masks respirators we have smaller
companies like American leather company
that converted its factories in North
Carolina in Texas to try to help make
gowns and masks as well we have success
stories like that all across the country
seeing everyday Americans check on the
elders in their lives their neighbors to
donate to the food banks to the blood
banks people really common together and
it turns out that Americans can be part
of the solution for something as serious
as this global pandemic we followed
instructions we stayed it was we slowed
the spread for 45 days and now as we
gradually and safely reopen in about 35
or so of the states Democrat and
Republican governor states will keep an
eye on that we put out almost three
weeks ago
Ainsley Stephen Bryant our three phase
approach to safe gradual reopening and
so the states have that we our health
team and our economic experts have told
everybody present your plans to us share
them with us and we'll help you you know
we'll help you see if they can port with
the guidelines and how best to support
your efforts but one of the guidelines
Kellyanne was if you want to enter phase
one you've got to have two weeks
where you've got negative growth of the
virus and you know you look at the
states that are reopening it doesn't
seem like that is the case so I think
some states are reopening in some areas
and and let's take a Florida for example
governor De Santis of Florida was here
last week he has three very hard-hit
counties as I understand there are
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
miles away from some of the beaches that
Rio reopened in the northern part of the
state I think you'll see examples like
that across the country also it depends
on the industry and it depends on the
individuals if you are a 72 year old
worker who had exposure or has
underlying conditions you may not go
back to work perhaps as quickly as say
somebody 30 years young 40 years younger
than you not exposure living alone
healthy asymptomatic so those that's one
example the other example is just to
show that we we as a as the federal
government support what the states are
deciding so long as they are comporting
with that let me just make clear to some
states flattened a long time ago some
states as dr. Burks has told us never
really had thank God a big surge so
they've been flat all along it would be
hard for them to decrease their numbers
when they've been pretty flat for a
while but if you don't see that surge
and then that's why our medical team
also says the Sentinel surveillance is
so important because we'll be able to
tell people hey there was a big outbreak
in your state a few hundred miles from
you but it was a wedding or it was a
nursing home or it was a prison we're
keeping our eye on that but it may not
affect you as much as if it were in your
neighborhood so I understand the house
made it clear last week they would like
to see Anthony foutch II the White House
said no you're not going to do that
where the word is he will the president
will let him go in front of a Senate
committee what could you tell us about
any member of the task force and
testifying sometime in May and can you
separate the chambers you have a
different policy per chamber our lawyers
are probably sorting that out
I heard that our health and our and all
of us our experts really focus and
continue to focus on this pandemic which
you've been doing for two straight
months at the White House
rather than but they say they are by
getting the latest from the task
well that's okay and listen if the
president has no problem with that
there's no executive privilege attached
to that based on the task force
conversations then I'll leave that to
the lawyers and to the different
testifiers I think it would shed a great
deal of light I just hope that the
people who are asking the questions are
asking intelligent rational questions
that are actually relevant to the
American health because we've seen what
they do before for example they say
stupid things like this is a job
interview this is a job interview for a
lifetime appointment about Brett
Kavanaugh let's believe all women or at
least those three women most of who then
retracted or didn't have corroborating
evidence so let's make sure that they
don't that they make use good use of the
question time of dr. fowey and other
members of this task force and they're
not doing the usual fishing expedition
because we had two years of collusion
nonsense then we tried to impeach a
president remove him from the case just
to be clear better be about health right
good I'm pretty clear the president said
no or the White House said no - Anthony
thought you to the house and I thought
said yes to the Senate yesterday that
seemed a little bit cloudy senator
schumer indicated he will be coming to
the Senate do you know if that's true he
will be going to the Senate and not to
go to the house no I'm not going to say
that today one way or the other I'm
saying it's up to the president and the
lawyers here if they were to say yes to
that and I didn't say they said yes to
that then I certainly hope people would
make good good time they would spend the
time in relevant fashion on behalf of
American health so that you have the the
infectious disease lead for this country
and for the task force they are talking
about the task force work and saying
that the mitigation tactics we all
undertook have actually helped to slow
the spread I've heard dr. Falchi say
that publicly and privately
look dr. Falchi I think he has a media
engagement at least daily so he as he's
got great exposure to the country in
terms of helping them to understand this
pandemic and what to do to protect
themselves and others sometimes those
questions are relevant and sometimes
they're not it's just a couple weeks ago
you had a reporter from different
Network basically shouting in very
abusive lis
accusing him of being a supplicant and
not being able to think on his own are
you here on your own free will
how insulting to to one of our two three
infectious disease doctors on the task
force working day and night to help all
of us so let's just make sure that if he
does you know if he can but but I think
that our work is is very clear every day
- from the task force you've had these
task force briefings we've made our
doctors our economist the president vice
president themselves cabinet members
available to the press available to the
people quite remarkably and if not
historically and transparently all right
Kellyanne let's talk about Michael Flynn
because so many things have just broken
this week we're learning now the FBI had
had priests at possibly in that room at
the White House and pankot who'd what do
you know about him this guy that I think
worked for the FBI and also participated
in in the Russia collusion and and
surveilling Carter pages phones and this
is Jim Jordan because Jim Jordan wants
some answers and he's asking for
Christopher rate to to speak about this
listen where's Chris Rabin he's been
he's been FBI director for two and a
half years what the documents we want
that 302 that was changed and we want to
talk to the agents who were there when
they interviewed Mike Flynn and why they
change that 302 so give us the documents
let us talk to mr. P Enka the guy who
was in the room with Peter struck when
the interviewed Mike Flynn that's what
we want to see Kelly and enlighten us
tell us about who was in that room at
the White House when the FBI interviewed
Michael Flynn when he didn't have an
attorney there and by the way his
attorneys now retweeting a tweet about
Christopher Reis she wants him fired I
think we I think sunlight is the best is
infected and that we should have it all
out there in terms of the transparency
and accountability here it's obvious the
president is absolutely correct Michael
Flynn was I castigated denigrating that
as he told the New York Post in an
interview yesterday probably treated
more unfairly than anybody else and he's
right and ladies and gentlemen the FBI
the Obama people frankly sent their
folks the obama-biden people sent their
folks here to the White House a few days
into our administration do they come
here to help do they come here to warn
us that Michael Flynn is a rush
asset or he's a no and he had been their
colleague President Barack Obama told
president-elect Trump you have two
things to worry about North Korea
Michael Flynn that's just odd stuff
those are the two the nuclear-capable on
North Korea and Michael Flynn a general
had served for three-plus decades with
distinction and for the Obama
administration which continue to give
him their top stop security clearance so
we will find out who was in that room
and why they were setting up we've
already seen that the notes in the
margin should we get him to lie or be
fired we already know that the fix was
in and I think that we are going and if
people say oh you know you're just
trying to investigate folks we went
through a two-year investigation on your
taxpayer dollar and we complied with
that in this White House nothing came of
it
the Muller investigation the malla
report the Muller testimony remember
those and then into the Ukrainian
investigation we have every need to know
transparently what happened and I do
think director ray should speak also I
think the current FBI directors to speak
I think the former FBI FBI director who
got a hero's welcome red carpet kill the
fatted calf treatment Jim Comey is
booked these prime time interviews he
lied - he's a liar and a leaker he lied
under oath in Congress he lied and
leaked his book is a roll of paper
towels at this point so I want to hear
also the people at the top echelon the
FBI who tried to prevent Donald Trump
from being elected where political and
their jobs on transpire
they continue to do that after he got
elected during transition and in the
early days of our administration through
Michael Flynn the newly installed
national security director we need to
know great Kellyanne before you go
breaking news you know down in Venezuela
Nicolas Maduro says his government
captured two Americans we believe they
could have been Special Forces he refers
to them as mercenaries and he says they
were in his country to try to kill him
what what's the White House story on
that right now
I like the national security folks if
not the president talk about that I'll
be leaving here shortly and maybe take
questions on the lawn from the press but
let me just repeat we don't believe
Medora is a legitimate president and
he's a thug as the president and the
Secretary of State and others have said
and also I just want to say when the
president visits Arizona today he's
doing one other thing in addition oh
honey honey well it's very significant
he's having a roundtable with Native
Americans he will be signing a new
proclamation for missing and murdered
indigenous women we had a big event here
in the oval office the end of November
we also have invested over eight billion
dollars in the tribal lands due to kovat
19 a major investment because they and
other vulnerable populations have been
disproportionately hard-hit and we want
to make sure the president is there to
speak with them directly and see that
that commitment is being made for them
well we'll keep you posted on the
Venezuela situation as it unfolds okay
all right I can't wait thanks so much
gonna be a busy day while